mexico's president Miguel Alemán welcomes
President Truman upon his arrival in Mexico
City on his good neighbor visit a spectacular
student festival is staged in his honor colorful
ancient costumes predominating the visitor
from the United States looks upon a pageant
symbolizing lasting friendship between the
southern and northern Republic's in Ottawa
President Truman is welcomed by Lord Alexander
and Prime Minister Mackenzie King Erie addresses
a joint session of the Canadian Parliament
we intend to cooperate actively and loyally
with all who earnestly seek as we do to build a
better world in which mankind can live in peace
and prosperity we count Canada in the forefront
of those who share these objectives and ideals
with such friends we face the future early
Fraser's demanded on the border to the north
Truman arrives in Rio de Janeiro as the
inter-american defense pact is ratified with
president Eureka Gaspar Dutra he reviews a great
parade in celebration of Brazil's 125 years of
Independence a nation's biggest Fiesta of the year
at Rio the president concludes his goodwill visit